Second announcement is that,
um,
the,
the movies,
the films I have done what I think is the way to do it and they will be
available.
I think the first one is available now and you can watch it in the privacy of
your rooms in whatever college who are,
um,
uh,
and uh,
you are too.
Please see them.
Um,
paths of glory goes with,
with next week.
And that's the first one.
And it's very short.
It's very good.
It's one of the first Kubrick films and it's about the mutinies.
And I will talk about the mutinies,
uh,
next week.
So please have seen the film by Monday.
Uh,
and then,
um,
what can you tell them in a,
in section how they do that?
I mean,
I,
I did it but I'm not sure how I did it.
Uh,
so they should be set up,
but it's a film you can,
another thing you can do is you can go down to film studies,
uh,
in the Whitney manage center and you can check out the film and watch it there.
I think you can take it back also,
but you can watch it on your computer screens.
So,
um,
uh,
but,
and those are the three.
And the first one is the first one.
And then the second one is the second one where I'm really awake today.
The second one is,
is a triumph of the will,
which will go with the fascism lecture and be sure to have seen it before.
Uh,
and the last one is a while on phone,
uh,
Louis Malle film,
which will be a subtitled in English.
Uh,
and I think,
yeah.
And,
um,
yeah,
it is.
And is that,
that goes with,
uh,
the,
the second to the last lecture.
So,
uh,
make sure you see it.
You see these films and they're not,
none of them are long and they're all great,
great,
great films.
So,
uh,
you know,
if you,
if you can buy into Kirk Douglas as a,
as a,
as a French soldier,
uh,
you have to suspend reality a little bit,
to do that.
Okay.
Any in any announcements,
things happening?
All right.
So today,
this lecture,
uh,
much of it just parallels the chapter because the origins there were one can be
confusing.
Uh,
and I just want to make those perfectly clear,
uh,
so that,
that you know,
this stuff.
So say help you read the,
read the chapter.
Um,
and also we used to have you read goodbye to all that,
which is very long,
but very good.
I Robert Graves and then we used the inevitable,
I'm all quiet on the western front,
but we,
we,
we suppressed those.
And,
and so,
uh,
it's even more important that you,
that you read the read the chapter.
So let me,
uh,
get into that.
And I'm,
I'm not gonna write all the terms on the board that I,
cause there's so many and I sent them around.
So it's just,
uh,
it's hard to see.
Anyway,
so what I have up here is,
uh,
when I talk about birth rates is between the drilling,
God darn it,
uh,
in the background anyway,
live births 1908 13 per 1000.
But I'll,
I'll go into that in a minute.
So let me,
uh,
let me start now.
So,
you know,
because World War One,
1914,
so many people wanted war and they,
they,
they ran to the God the last and chanted up our about law.
I bear lie and drank a lots of champagne and then home button,
the huff in Berlin,
they,
they chanted a knock pop.
He's not a,
he's a,
nobody knew that the war was going to last over four years and kill millions of
people and uh,
uh,
mark the end of,
um,
of,
of four empires and arguably help contribute to the,
to the end of the fifth.
That is the British empire.
Uh,
the impetus toward d colon colonization that comes out of world war one.
you know,
nobody,
nobody knew what that there was that the war that was supposed to be over.
Um,
by December,
I wasn't going to be over by December.
And outside of a couple of journalists who had been following the Russell
Japanese war in Manchuria had seen kind of the evolution of trenches.
Nobody could,
nobody predicted that kind of war.
And I'll talk about military strategy at the end today or at the,
at in the plans for the war or depending on time,
the timing,
uh,
the end of,
or the beginning of next of next hour.
But,
so this makes the origins of the war so much more important.
And there are certainly in terms of diplomatic history,
there's no other event in the history of the world that has been so poured over
than the diplomatic origins of World War One.
The famous entangling alliances,
the host of cards that collapses,
all of those very familiar,
uh,
images.
Uh,
and after the war,
I,
I had this great uncle who fought in the war.
I mean,
great,
great uncle.
He was an old dude when I was a very little guy.
Um,
and he had,
he'd been in France in 1917 and at the end of the war,
I remember when I was little kid,
he gave me the,
you know,
the sort of printed out books showing that the Germans had started the war and
there was the official account of the origins of World War One.
And of course the fact that that the end of the war,
the war ends with German troops inside France,
uh,
this has a huge,
huge impact on what happens because of two things.
Looking ahead.
One,
it became very easy for the German right to say we weren't defeated.
We were stabbed in the back by who?
By the Jews,
by the Communists,
by the Socialists.
And secondly,
because Germany was defeated,
they had to sign on the,
on the bottom line saying,
uh,
we started the war alone.
We alone the famous war guilt clause,
war guilt clause.
Now the Germans didn't start the war alone and I'll leave it to you to decide
whether their responsibility,
the famous blank check given to Austria,
Hungary is more important than the roles of other states.
Uh,
uh,
Russia declaring mobilization,
which was tantamount to an act of war for reasons we'll come to,
uh,
or France,
for that matter.
But that's why the origins of a world war one are so important.
And the other reason is that clearly world war one unleashes the demons of the
20th century that the guy,
the kind of racist stuff,
the even somewhat genocidal stuff was out there in the public domain,
but world war one turns it loose.
And we talk about,
I hope,
convincingly the Europe of,
of extremes,
which is a title of a wonderful book by Eric Hobsbawm.
Um,
and one extreme being being communism.
But the other extreme,
which was more print all which was more,
uh,
victorious,
more overwhelming,
uh,
in Europe was the rise of fascism.
And in particularly the rise of national socialism and,
and this stuff was out there,
but national socialism and the Nazis cannot be understanding.
I understood what that,
where we one.
So that's why this stuff on the origins,
this diplomatic history is so important.
So that's why I'm paralleling what,
uh,
what you are reading now that people,
if you ask people in the 1880s and 1890s who will fight in the next war,
many people in German,
most people in Germany,
uh,
and many people in France would say that it'll be the Germans fighting the
French because of Alsace.
Lauryn,
other people as we'll see,
particularly in the 1890s,
will say,
no,
it's,
it's the British and the French who are going to be fighting colonial rivalries.
[inaudible] showed up and,
and all that business.
But the one that,
you know,
as I in what you're reading is I put it though the old hatred that,
that,
that is cannot be put off stage.
Uh,
it,
during the entire period,
even when French and British relations or at their nadir at their worst is that
between Germany,
United,
the empire proclaimed in the hall of mirrors at Versailles Chateaux devout side,
uh,
and France.
Because after all,
the French had to give the most second,
most industrialized region,
one of the most prosperous regions that is Alsace and much of it then to
Germany.
And I'm going to end up with an incident that looked like war was possibly going
to break out between Germany and France.
And that is the Zalburn Rza van incident.
And talk a little bit about Al Sassal random stuff that is,
and then,
uh,
in the book later just to make it,
I make it clear and it is complicated because the French could never accept the
fact that Alsace and much of Lohan was now German.
Now this is again,
remember we talked about nationalism and constructed identity.
Most people in Alsace and in those parts of the hen that became part of the,
the second hike,
the second empire,
where do they speak?
They spoke German dialect.
They did not speak French more about that later.
There was bilingualism.
But that's interesting.
If you ask them,
you know,
what nationality are you,
are are you?
And they reply in German,
I am French.
You know,
if you were somebody doing a survey now,
you'd be sort of shocked by that.
Uh,
but I mean,
these are complex,
these identities.
So anyway,
um,
the rivalry between,
between France and,
and,
and Germany was already always there.
If you went to the [inaudible] called in Paris,
the statue of straws,
wool,
the tone of straws,
boy,
which,
uh,
you know,
important European capital now,
but I've been a of of the new Europe for better,
for worse,
was covered in morning cloth for much of the period because it,
it had been amputated.
They used this image often that,
that the right arm of,
of,
of France had been,
had been amputated,
uh,
in the settlement after the Franco,
a German war.
So that rivalry is there and,
and French military planners right to the whole period at the time of Boulogne
Jay who you can,
who,
uh,
what was one who built this reputation,
you can read already have read about the General Asocial boot on Jay,
you know,
he is Mr Revenge and,
and a military planners said when the war comes a,
we will move into Alsace and take a Alsace and parts of Lorenn back and then we
will move to Berlin.
Simple just like that until the very end.
That's their military strategy attack.
They're going to attack and get back.
Alsace-Lorraine what the Germans planned to do has a lot to do with the way,
the way,
the way the war starts.
And we will get there.
Now the second big rivalry in Europe,
and again,
think of the 28th of June,
1914,
Sarah Evil 16 year old,
heavily armed Gobbler oh princip is that between Russia and Austria,
Hungary and their rivalry is over the south Slavs who are within the Austrian
Guerin empire and the Serbs who are not,
but who provide a constant force for,
um,
a destabilization in the region.
Now,
as you know,
since the time of Catherine the great,
she set her eyes on [inaudible] on Istanbul,
Constantinople,
same.
They're the same city,
uh,
on the straights,
on access to the Black Sea.
Uh,
that was always going to be this drive of Russia to,
uh,
to,
to the straights.
And as you know,
later in a Turkey allies with,
uh,
with Germany.
Um,
but the big rivalry,
uh,
is,
is in terms of Russian influence,
the stabilizing influence seeing itself as the protector,
the mother of all of the Slavic peoples is a permanent force of destabilization
in the Austrian Hungarian Empire on ironically,
the guy who gets off along with his wife I the arts to Francis Ferdinand and his
wife,
he was one of the more,
more,
I mean,
he was a prejudiced,
uh,
figure,
in many ways,
but he was considered a moderate because he somehow,
he believed that the South Slavs should have kind of a third status along with a
Ed possibly,
uh,
along with Germany and externally with,
excuse me,
Austria and Hungary within sort of a tripe park,
Tate,
uh,
empire.
Uh,
and he,
and of course,
he gets gunned down and what comes next is the blank check where the Germans
say,
do what you want to settle this situation.
And the famous ultimatum to,
uh,
to Serbia by Austria,
Hungary and the Russian government stirs up Pan Slavic fervor in the Balkans
that they work consistently to,
uh,
to do that.
Um,
you know,
there are religious ties,
the Orthodox religion,
uh,
there's ties of,
of Alphabet,
Cyrillic,
alphabet,
uh,
used in Serbia,
cerebral creations,
the same language but,
but spoken language.
So Serb friends and Croatian friends would,
would deny that in some ways,
but basically it's the same spoken language,
but the Serbs use cyrillic alphabet,
uh,
which is what the Russians use.
Uh,
and the Croats,
uh,
who are Catholic,
use,
you know,
the alphabet use didn't,
uh,
in,
in western Europe.
So,
um,
the European alliance system,
this entangling alliances hinges on French and German immunity and the competing
interests of Russia and Austria,
Hungary in the Balkans.
And it also hinges on Bismarck who was in many ways an odious guy,
but very,
very clever guy.
His fear that Germany would have to fight a war on two fronts.
And so what these powers are doing or looking for allies,
and as Bismark said,
it's interesting he said it in French showing that in many ways French was still
the language of diplomacy.
He said in a,
when you've got these great powers,
five of them in quotes,
you have to be Artois.
There have to be,
you have to be with the free and not the two.
And its worst nightmare in Bismarck was somebody who he said he liked the lie
awake at night and hate,
uh,
his worst fear was having to fight the Russians and having to fight the French
at the same time.
And so when he encourages the French to get into the imperial game at the
beginning,
he's doing that to try to,
you know,
he tried to get them to blow off a little steam out there in Africa.
My Map of Africa is here,
remember the,
the line about the map of the map of Europe.
And so his,
he said,
here's the exact quote,
all international politics reduces itself to this formula.
Try to be a 12.
As long as the world is governed by the unstable equilibrium of five great
powers,
Germany,
Austria,
Hungary,
Russia,
Britain and France.
And these treaties,
these arrangements,
that is the emergence of the triple alliance and the emergence of the triple
entente.
Uh,
the,
you know,
at the time of the war,
these are,
uh,
you know,
Italy is a,
is,
is up for grabs,
open to the highest bidder and Italy will go to war despite having been a member
of original of the alliance with Austria,
Hungary and Germany.
It will go to war on the allied side because the allies promise the more in
1915.
Um,
but that,
that's another story,
but that's very important in the emergence of fascism in Italy because Italy
after the war though,
nominally victorious does not get what it wants.
It does not get the donation coast.
It does not get the [inaudible] mountains,
uh,
because if you fought a war based on national claims,
why turn around give,
give regions and they have only a minority of Italian populations to Italy and
Benito Mussolini,
uh,
goes from being a socialist to being a fascist helps create that party.
Uh,
based upon this idea that Italian Italy had been screwed.
They never got what they were supposed to in,
in,
in World War One.
And so that's how he comes to power as a fascist.
Didn't,
as you know,
in,
in 1922,
so in 1879,
Bismarck forges this cornerstone alliance between Germany and Austria,
Hungary,
uh,
and it's predicated on German support for Habsburg opposition to the expansion
of Russian interests in the Balkans.
And you can see in this the origins of the famous blank check in the summer,
hot summer as it was in 1914 and in the,
in 1880 Italy allies with Germany and Austria,
Hungary forming the triple alliance.
But the wording is such that,
uh,
it doesn't necessarily bring Italy in,
into the war.
And as I said,
Italy will come in and I'm the side to Austria,
Germany,
Austria,
Hungary and Germany and Italy comes in,
uh,
as I just said,
in 1915 now the details of these treaties and these,
these,
these diplomats are still under the influence of Metro neck and,
and,
and all that,
that the details are not known,
but the,
the outlines are,
are,
are known.
I mean,
the details are,
uh,
are not known,
but the outlines of these trees are,
are basically,
um,
uh,
basically no.
And at one seem right through the period is every time,
every time that Russia seeks to expand its influence in the Balkans,
Austria,
Hungary gets concerned and they turned to Germany saying,
uh,
you will back us.
You will back us,
won't you?
When they say yes,
of course we will back you.
And in the end what happens is that the blank check goes to,
uh,
after the ultimatum to Serbia by Austria,
Hungary,
uh,
do whatever you want to settle the situation.
We will vacuum all the way.
Now why does Germany become encircled a diplomatically and ultimately in war?
How does it happen that Russia czarist autocratic Russia allies with Republican
France that the czar,
the oppressor of,
of the non Russian people's,
especially the Jews,
uh,
in Russia comes to Paris in 1889 and they name a beautiful bridge after him.
The poem at least twice the bridge of Alexander is a third.
And that the marine band learns the theme song of the Czars
and the Socialists go wild in France.
And how can you ally with these people who are repressing?
Socialists are oppressing nationalities.
There were oppressing everybody.
And run this,
this,
this police state.
And so the last thing that Bismarck wanted are these two big states to,
um,
to come together on either side of him.
How does this happen?
Both France and Russia are outside of the triple alliance,
uh,
which you already know,
but there's another reason.
As a matter of fact,
I read about four or five years ago,
there are still French companies trying to get their money back from Russia
because they lost their money in 1917,
uh,
when the Bolsheviks came to power and ultimately nationalized industries,
big industries particularly,
it is economic,
uh,
in that,
one of the old things that people say about the French economy,
but it's still true,
is that French money,
uh,
investments,
much of it goes outside of France.
They'd build the railroads in Spain,
uh,
but they invest heavily in Russian industry and in Russian,
railroads.
Uh,
and so these economic ties are very important.
I mean,
there are also cultural ties.
because of the,
you know,
because of the popularity of French in the,
in aristocratic circles within,
in Russia.
But in other hand,
there were lots of Russian nobles who spoke German,
uh,
you know,
who lived in Koenigsberg,
which is still,
you know,
the sort of enclave now that is that it is still part of a Russia sort of stuck
between Poland and Lithuania.
Um,
but the most important reason is that Russian invest French investment in Russia
increases dramatically in the 1880s and 1890s.
And that,
you know,
France seeks and ally against Germany and that relations between Russia,
uh,
and,
and Germany and this is already obvious,
you've already discerned this,
uh,
are,
are going to deteriorate because of this Tinder relationship between Austria,
Hungary and uh,
uh,
and Germany over the Balkans.
And in the very end,
I mean,
one of the,
the ludicrous aspects of this whole damn thing is it just as they're about to go
to war and just as,
as a Tsar Nicholas,
the second about whom we'll come back and discuss one day,
um,
he signs the mobilization order and mobilization for reasons I'll come back to
is tantamount to an act of war.
He's dashing off letters to his dearest cousin willy.
And really is writing back to my dear cousin Nikki.
These people are related,
they're cousins,
but international circumstances and the tensions over the bulk and French fears
of Germany,
uh,
bring Russia and France together and the French were in band sing or plays a
whatever the theme song of,
of the Russians.
Ours is when they,
it certainly wasn't doctors,
Trivago,
but whatever when,
when,
when they arrive.
Um,
and so for the Russian government that blames Austria,
Hungary,
uh,
for,
trying to undercut what they view as their logical,
uh,
influence in the Balkans,
um,
and Germany will back them right away.
So in 1892,
France and Russia sign a military treaty,
uh,
that,
that says,
uh,
that,
that there'll be a military response if,
if the other word attacked by Germany or by one or more of its allies and they
form a formal alliance in 1894.
Now what about Britain?
What about Britain?
Now,
one of the things that the British don't want to ally with anybody and they're
on bad terms with the French and they're on bad terms with the Russians.
To make a long story short,
the great game as they called it,
a rivalry over Afghanistan,
over the entire universe or extension of that,
that frontier in,
into,
um,
into uh,
uh,
into Asia,
means that,
uh,
the chances of of Great Britain,
Britain joining an alliance,
uh,
with in alliance with Russia and with France seems,
extremely dim.
Britain wants to control the seas and to go it alone,
but they discover a,
a fact it shouldn't have surprised them in the Boer War in South Africa is they
don't have any friends.
The nobody supports what they're doing in South Africa.
And it's better to have an ally in a,
in a world that gets increasingly dangerous.
Um,
and what happens Oh,
gradually is that the rivalry between Germany,
again,
make a long story short between Germany and Britain ultimately will cause
Britain to look for,
uh,
allies and that suddenly it seems less probable that that France and Britain
will go to war.
Now what is the nature of this,
uh,
this,
increasingly bitter rivalry between Germany and Britain?
One is obvious Africa.
That's one
second economic
in that the German economy is growing by leaps and bounds.
It is the number one country in,
in,
in chemistry,
the chem,
the hope.
Those of you that are there are chemists.
The whole,
you know,
the university system,
uh,
we're in,
in Britain university system isn't terribly practical,
but in,
in Germany that,
you know,
chemistry is part of what,
what,
what they do in the German universities,
which are great universities and they begin to lap the British in,
in,
in chemistry,
chemical productions.
Uh,
and they catch up and go ahead and steal too.
And so,
um,
this is a big rivalry.
I and the British government is be,
it begins to run a scared because the city is running scared.
And third is this famous naval rivalry that which Paul Kennedy and my colleague
and friend has written a book,
the Anglo German naval rivalry is that the Germans start turning off these huge
ships and then the British respond.
They produced the dreadnought,
which becomes a symbol for these huge,
powerful battleships,
powerful battleships that says nothing had ever been seen before.
And,
uh,
the millet,
the naval leagues in both countries.
Again,
this is the culture of imperialism,
the culture of,
of aggressive nationalism.
Ah,
put huge pressure on governments to throw every available resource in the
building of,
of,
of more and more,
uh,
ships and Britain,
which has all always controlled,
basically controlled the seas since the,
the armada and the late,
uh,
a defeat of the Spanish armada and the late 16th century.
They're running scared now again,
you know,
you can't look ahead and say,
Aha,
but there was only one naval battle of any consequence in,
in,
uh,
in World War One,
w at the battle of Jutland off the coast of Denmark.
And,
and it's,
it's kind of a draw,
but basically the Germans are forced back into port,
so they lose.
But nobody in the British couldn't anticipate that.
So their fear of Germany and the saber rattling of the thoroughly irresponsible
idiot,
uh,
of Wilhelm,
the second,
uh,
helps make it possible to imagine in alliance with this Nikki French.
Now in the 1890s,
there were a lot of war novels,
uh,
about future wars.
And this in itself reflects the fact that that many people thought there would
be another war.
Again,
they didn't know it's gonna be a war of four and a half years,
but they think they're going to be another war.
And when I,
I assure you,
I've never read the following book,
but one of the more successful was uh,
uh,
for a brief time with this sort of book about um,
a future war and it's in the area,
I guess that's in the early eighties and nineties or about the time of a show to
me,
but it's in the 80s,
1890s,
or maybe the first couple of years of the,
of the 20th century.
It doesn't matter.
Dover,
the middleclass of Dover are out parading in the rain round in the rain on a
Sunday morning,
miserable weather.
And they suddenly find that Dover's been taking over,
taking over by the sneaky French that they've been digging a tunnel under the
English Channel.
Now there was no Napoleon wanting to dig a tunnel under the channel.
There is a tunnel under the English Channel,
the channel,
the trains rocket along at least until they got to Britain and then who could
applaud along at about two kilometers an hour.
But then they've improved that side of it anyway.
There's sort of a French bias but too bad.
Um,
so they,
they suddenly find that there's a strolling along in the pouring rain horizontal
rain that as these sneaky French that there were soldiers all over and taking
these sort of national stereotypes.
It's the French are disguised as waiters.
It wearing dirty waiter uniforms and under there,
this is the British image.
I would even comment on,
you know what English kitchens would have been like or something,
but I had to be a cheap shot.
But,
uh,
under these,
under these towels where a sneaky weapons,
uh,
and they take over Dover and then of course the British get it together and they
drive them back into the tunnel and shoot a few and then they submit up the
tunnel and then parliament passes lots of more battleship bills,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
The future,
future novel.
But there's another one four or five years later,
and I haven't read this one either and I ain't going to read it.
And the people in Whitby speaking of uh,
or Scarborough,
speaking of horizontal rain,
uh,
in the east coast,
they wake up and they see these huge German battleships just lobbing shells that
can reach and blow up in York,
lobbing one shell after another.
And the sequel isn't very interesting,
but the bridge parliament passes even more bills.
And then the battle of the battleships of the good guys in quotes go and blow up
the battleship to the bad guys.
And,
and everybody can go back to,
uh,
eating odd things on a Sunday morning.
So how does it happen that that scenario is reversed and what,
what the future will be?
Well,
I've just explained it,
it has to do with the fears of,
of these states of Germany and that the crises,
which you can read about the Moroccan crises in 1905,
uh,
it makes even firmer this military alliance,
it's called an entente or,
or which I word in English too,
or a an understanding.
But basically it's an alliance.
And by 1905,
they were already saying,
look,
our navy,
the British navy,
we'll take care of the North Sea and the channel,
and you guys take care of the Mediterranean.
Uh,
the,
the crisis in 1911,
the second Moroccan crisis,
uh,
which you know,
which pushes a Germany and France close to war,
uh,
affirms all of the above things that I've said.
Now,
don't get the idea that in 19,
uh,
11 things are more dangerous than 1910 and 1910,
they're more dangerous.
In 19 nine,
again,
this or hydraulic model of everything,
pressure building up and finally there is war.
It doesn't work like that,
but that these alliances become firmed up and of these,
uh,
you know,
these great powers,
um,
that,
that Britain and France and Russia ended up in.
Bismarck was dead by then,
but in his worst,
worst nightmare of being a twat of being three.
Now the French by the Va had another reason to be particularly,
yeah,
particularly,
particularly eager to have an alliance is that an odd thing happens in la.
Better false.
In most of France,
the French population stops growing.
It just stops as of 1846 47 it's regionally specific in Brittany and in,
in the the,
the ovarian,
you in the center of France,
people are still turning out babies.
You still have huge families.
We have friends.
One of them just died for older people and they were,
grew up in misery in the mountains,
misery.
They had 13 children in 12 children.
They were one of the 12 or 13 children.
But in most of France,
that's not the case.
And in one part of southwestern France,
when people had a second baby,
they received a condolence card.
Isn't that bizarre?
The French population stops growing.
Why there a couple of reasons.
This is just an aside,
but it's interesting.
The Napoleonic code remember ends primogeniture.
So you've got to divide up the plot of land into the two or three or an to a
birth control.
There's two arguments is that the peasants started,
uh,
and then it filters up to the middle classes or the middle class starts and
filters down.
It depends on where in France,
but they stop having children.
Look at this,
I wrote it on board but,
and maybe in the book,
hadn't even remember,
but here's live births.
1908 1913 per a thousand,
uh,
Italy 32.4,
Austria,
31.9,
Germany,
29.3,
England 24.9,
USA 24.3,
France 19.5.
That means that his solo,
the French population would have literally not grown had it not been for
immigrants,
immigrants then where people coming from Italy and from Switzerland,
but mostly from mostly from Italy and from Spain to some and from Belgium.
So what's the effect of this is,
is that there's this enormous crisis it has to do also with this sort of
threatened realty.
Why do we have fewer children with some matter with us?
Francis became into a feminine,
etc. Etc.
You can just hear the language of this.
Women are not serving this date.
Why are they not having babies anymore?
What's the matter?
They want to vote.
Uh,
is this getting in the way with having a,
having a,
uh,
babies?
It can be sent off to war.
So it causes an enormous problem and it's discussed all over the place,
particularly by,
by the nationalists.
We don't have enough children jumping ahead and I'll come back to this very
done.
1916 the Germans say we're not going to take the forts at done there in
printable in prem.
Unshakeable,
uh,
cannot be taken.
They cannot be pre,
um,
what,
but we will make them pay so many hundreds of thousands of people that we will
bleed them and there'll be forced to sue for peace.
There wasn't fucking Heine was the general,
we won't take the forts do,
I'm on Vole but we will kill so many hundreds of thousands of people and we can
afford to have lose a hundreds of thousands of people because our birth rate is
higher.
Nice for the people sent into all of this stuff.
More about that later.
So this has a big effect.
You know,
if you're going to go to war and get Alsace and run back and it's,
Germany gets more and more aggressive,
irresponsible,
no question about it.
In an age of aggressive nationalism,
you better have somebody else to help you out.
Cause there was a lot of them and they blew us away in 1870,
71.
And they,
they defeated,
they didn't blow away but they've faded Austria,
Prussia defeated Austria in 1866 cementing its role as the most important power
in,
uh,
in Europe.
So,
um,
that helps as well.
Now
the French fears and all that.
Now a couple more
points.
I just want to give you an example from this,
and I mentioned it just briefly,
but it's about how this works,
how small incidents in a complicated world of national rivalries and competing
identities can almost,
almost launched.
The war took Bam.
It took the assassination of Francis Ferdinand.
The started all off.
There would've been a war sometime.
And this is the case of [inaudible].
Erin in German is [inaudible] in French Sav,
er,
any,
a very nice little town went designer and got to see all these places.
I went to sovereign,
there's nice canal runs through it now I'll sauce.
And so I was woo,
we're next to France in 1681,
uh,
by,
the [inaudible] maniac,
uh,
Louis the 14th says they had been part of France a very long time and in 1871
for reasons,
you know,
they become part of,
of,
um,
uh,
of Germany.
But this incident adds a van.
What it does is it reinforces the stereotypes that the French have a of the
Germans and the Germans have,
uh,
of,
of the French,
the image of German quest for domination and aggressiveness and the role of the
German army,
which seems to know,
have absolutely no,
uh,
no limits as that someone once said about pressure that it was,
it was a state tacked onto an army.
And the Zoll veteran affair seem to indicate that Germany,
uh,
was,
still,
uh,
the same way.
Now if you go up to Alsace,
you go up to the voltage mountains,
there's this route called the Husa.
They cracked her.
So the root of the,
of,
of the peaks.
And you can look down into the bush,
which was France,
you know,
until 19,
uh,
still is France.
But,
uh,
from what had been,
um,
uh,
German el sauce.
And you can see all of these monuments put up by German hiking clubs,
uh,
a a to try to reaffirm this German identity,
that,
that people had and identity is extremely,
extremely complex thing.
But,
um,
first of all,
what is clear is that the vast majority of the population spoke German.
Now,
whether this makes them feel German or not,
that,
that that's,
you know,
it's,
it's not sure,
but let me give you a couple examples.
I didn't send this around.
It's too much,
but let's say that for the total of a Gr of Alsace and Lorraine,
the parts that were annexed into,
uh,
the German of hike,
um,
that is a number of communes that in which German with the dominant German
dialect was the dominant language.
It's 1,225 in which French was the dominant language was 385.
Um,
and the percentage of the population has spoke German.
It's 77%.
The population that spoke French as their major language,
12% are some bilingualism but not a whole lot actually and 10% sort of neither.
And that they were probably more or less perfectly bilingual because of uh,
uh,
because of uh,
of intermarriage.
Um,
and so,
you know,
when the Germans come in,
um,
in,
you know,
after 1871,
they are better than what the French did after we were one.
The French tried to just,
just rip German out as a language of,
of,
of instruction,
get rid of all the street signs in German.
The Germans are a little more delicate in the way that they do things,
but they want German is,
is,
uh,
is the language of the administration.
But another important point is that they don't trust the l sessions,
even though they speak German,
they don't trust them that Alsace and those parts of Loran are not there or next
into the hike,
but they don't have the same rights as a region that the other parts of Germany,
like Virgin Bergen Bavaria have and that German deputies from Alsace.
And those parts of the,
and don't have the right to vote on issues of war.
For example,
in the Reichstag,
they are not trusted because they are seen as potentially disloyal to the hike.
The idea is that they have been infected with Frenchness.
Now part of this is religious in that,
you know,
it's so complex.
Alsace is a,
is a wonderfully interesting area.
Uh,
it's has the largest percentage of Protestants in France outside of I'll dash in
the,
in the south center.
It's also got a large percentage of Jews who had been victimized by antisemitic
riots and after 1848 but the majority of population is Catholic.
The German empire,
going back to the couture comp of Bismarck,
the war against the Catholic still doesn't really trust the Catholics.
You've got Catholics in Bavaria,
usually very right wing Catholics and Bavaria.
You've got Catholics in the Rheinland,
you've got some Catholics up north and the palatinate and you've got a lot of
Catholics in Alsace.
And so they don't trust them,
basically don't trust them.
And so relations between the German troops who as in the case of Spain are not
coming from that region.
Spanish people occupying in Catalonia come from Galicia or they come from
Castillo.
So they won't be infected by the local population for the point of view of the
Spanish state.
And so the troops that are in El sauce or not from Alsace cause they don't trust
them.
And so tensions are very good.
And so what happens in,
in,
in Zavon,
uh,
it a place where military civil relations aren't terribly good in this town of
8,000 people,
uh,
is that,
there was an incident that gets blown out of proportion.
Uh,
there's a,
um,
uh,
there's some drilling there,
drilling.
The German soldiers are always drilling and they're drilling and,
and,
and the,
uh,
the,
um,
the commander makes a crack about the outstations stations and he calls him an
extremely unfortunate scatological term that he met to refer to all our
stations.
And he essentially says,
well,
if you beat the hell out of those people will be doing a service to all.
So this gets around.
And one of the reasons that relations weren't very good,
this particular town is because there was a German officer who was,
uh,
had the bad idea of sleeping with a 14 year old girl.
And so some of the local guys go get this guy in this room and just pound them
into a well deserved pulp.
And so it spins out of control.
And so what happens is on both sides in Berlin and Paris,
this becomes a huge incident confirming the stereotype of the other.
Uh,
and,
uh,
there's a nasty language.
Beckman Beckman Halweg hold veg,
who was the chancellor then,
you know,
assess some over the top things about,
uh,
you know,
about,
about the French and the influence of France and Alsace,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And that the French are planning a war and the French government in a,
in a,
in a time when there is a nationalist revival,
at least among the elites,
uh,
in France,
they respond in kind and everything gets big titles.
I big teach for big,
uh,
headlines and stuff like that.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
they,
they don't go to war.
But what it does is it reaffirms the stereotypes and it,
it,
it makes people a little more edgy now in 1913 but well before that military
planners,
yes,
I have three minutes and that's just what I need.
Military planners are looking ahead to the next war.
The French we've already talked about,
they have a not terribly poetically,
uh,
um,
designated plan number 18,
which is to invade El Sauce.
Lauren,
with a long,
that's all you need.
They said a long patriotic frenzy,
fury.
All you need is to be on the offensive.
And that's the end of it by the way.
They invade wearing red pants and they can be shot picked out through the fog.
Finally in 1914 till they put it a little less,
uh,
bright colors on.
Now how,
how are the Germans going to fight a war on two fronts?
How you going to do that?
They're afraid of the Russians.
Why?
There's a lot of Russians and the other peoples and they think it's going to
take about two weeks for the Russian army.
Once mobilization is declared that the big bear will roll their forces toward,
uh,
toward the German frontier in a German Poland.
So how are you going to win the war in two weeks
if you invade France?
Not Throughout to lsaw slow em.
But if you,
you know,
invade well,
I mean,
you know,
you're going to a big trouble.
You're gonna run into fortification.
So how you going to invade France?
The only way you can defeat them and a guy called Schlieffen whose name I wrote
it in there but I sent around to you,
is that you have to invade Belgium.
And from his point of view,
the Netherlands still Moltke his successor takes the Netherlands how they
question Belgium had been declared independent and neutral in 1831.
If you go into Belgium,
the idea is you invade Belgium,
you get through the big Ford at the edge,
get through the kind of rough country,
well,
which is not too much.
And then you hit the block,
the flatlands and you roll toward the English Channel.
And the last thing,
sleeping is poignantly,
he said,
it has said on his deathbed was the last soldier.
His right arm should touch the English Channel and then you turn down and you
put Paris in a headlock and they will sue for peace and you will beat them in
two weeks before the big bear can come moseying along slowly.
That's why mobilization was tantamount to an act of war because it puts,
it starts to timetable
that they've got to feed them in two weeks.
What happens if you go through Belgium for the point of view of the British is
bad enough to have the disease?
He Funche across the channel.
But what if you've got the Germans and all stemmed eating moves feet?
What if you have the Germans in na?
What if you have the Germans across the channel to big time enemies?
A very short choppy boat ride away.
So what this is going to do,
it's going to reaffirm the alliance and Sir Edward Gray,
the one who said most famously and he got it right,
lights are going out in Europe.
They will not be released again in our lifetime.
He at this point,
he's the,
the British hesitate,
the French said,
well,
the word honor be struck from the,
from the British English dictionary.
The French ambassador is chasing around,
uh,
a high official in the,
in the czarist regime in Russia saying you must back us all the way.
And so the invasion guarantees that the worst nightmare of near night mirror of
Bismark will come true.
That they will be Artois.
And the fact that it doesn't work out for variety of reasons,
the way the German high command,
uh,
intended in the way Schlieffen intended.
And Moltke means that they don't,
for reasons I'll come back to can't get Paris in that headlock forced them to
sue for peace and the race to the sea begins to try to out flank as an a game.
If you will take a ridiculous analogy.
The outside Linebacker,
and they ended up at the sea and then shovels and defensive weapons like
barbwire and machine guns become the weapons of the war.
And that explains why there wasn't,
and subsequently could never be a knock out punch
and why millions of people died in and around those trenches.